one situation where covariances show up
is when we try to calculate the variance
of a sum of random variables so let us
look at the variance of the sum of two
random variables X 1 and X 2 if the two
random variables are independent then we
know that the variance of the sum is the
sum of the variances but let us now look
at what happens in the case where we may
have dependence by definition the
variance is the expected value of the
difference of the random variable were
interested in from it's expected value
squared and now we rearrange terms here
and write what is inside the expectation
as follows we put together X 1 2 with
the term minus the expected value of X 1
and then X 2 together with negative the
expected value of X 2
so now we have the square of the sum of
two terms we expand the quadratic to
obtain expected value of the square of
the first term plus the square of the
second term plus two times
a cross term
and what do we have here the expected
value of the first term is just the
variance of X 1 the expected value of
this second term is just the variance of
X 2 and finally the cross term the
expected value of it we recognize that
it is the same as the covariance of X 1
with X 2 and we also have this factor of
2 up here so this is the general form
for the variance of the sum of two
random variables in the case of
independence the covariance is 0 and we
just have the sum of the two variances
but when the random variables are
dependent it is possible that the
covariance will be nonzero and we have
one additional term let us now
generalize this calculation here is for
reference and comparison the formula for
the case where we add two random
variables but now let us look at the
variance of the sum of many of them to
keep the calculation simple we are going
to assume that the means are 0 but the
final conclusion will also be valid for
the case of non zero means since we have
a song 0 means the variance is the same
as the expected value of the square of
the random variable involved which is
this one and now we expand this
quadratic to obtain the expected value
of we will have a bunch of terms of this
kind where I ranges from 1 up to n and
then we will have a bunch of cross terms
of the form X I XJ and we obtain one
cross term for each choice of I from 1
to N and for each choice of j from 1 to
n as long as i is different from j so
overall here this sum will have N
squared minus n terms
now we use linearity to move the
expectation inside the summation and so
from here we obtain the sum of the
expected value of X I squared which is
the same as the variance of X I since we
assumed zero means and similarly here
we're going to get this double sum over
eyes that are different from J of the
expected value of X I XJ and in the case
of zero means again this is the same as
the covariance of X I with XJ and so we
have obtained this general formula that
gives us the variance of a sum of random
variables if the random variables have
zero covariances then the variance of
the sum is the sum of the variances and
this happens in particular when the
random variables are independent for the
general case where we may have
dependencies and nonzero covariances
then the variance of the sum involves
also all the possible covariances
between the different random variables
and let me finally add that this formula
is also valid for the general case where
we do not assume that the means are zero
and the derivation is very similar
except that there's a few more symbols
that are floating around